apparently Disney's new show Echo is
woke and the person that has made me
this angry hasn't even watched the
show Welcome to Sid Trek your Sci-Fi TV
and Movie Channel having a bit of a
[Music]
rant I'm
genuinely quite
angry so I had a couple of comments on a
video I did yesterday talking about how
the new Marvel Echo series really does
remind me of the Netflix series of
Daredevil and that sort of quality I
talked about how the use of sound was so
important because the character's deaf
and so on and so on and I got a comment
directly to me not on the channel but
directly to me
saying this is one more woke nonsense TV
show by Disney that they have to have it
has to be a Native American
disabled woman why can't it just be a
normal superhero show So I responded
that going look and the fact that she's
a woman she's disabled doubly disabled
she's also lost a leg so physically and
you know and she's
deaf and the fact that she's a woman in
Native America has got nothing to do
with it it's a TV show what if it was a
a white anglosaxon with one leg would
that be okay or just or a disability
problem as well the response that I said
was and the response I got was this is
the same old rubbish they always send us
it's woke it's woke and then a couple of
things that I'm not going to repeat on
the channel because it was
offensive Center myself Center breathe
through the
ignorance I have always agreed that
there has been an issue that people call
woke I hate the term I hate it but
people call woke so I was stuck with it
it feels
like and there has been a problem that
sometimes TV shows movies Etc the agenda
has come before the
story but science fiction in particular
and Comics have
always sort of tried to have some social
justice involved in them for the love of
God the whole point of Android
in every sci-fi thing you've ever read
or watched or seen or whatever is about
freedom and slavery and things like this
because they're a machine trying to be a
human being and the whole it you know it
creates that whole metaphor for freedom
and what is to be human look at the
episodes of data we saw in the Next
Generation that's what it's
about what is it to be human what is it
to be free
this the point of of of that sort of
storyline in something like Marvel's
Echo and I've not seen it all yet so
don't get me wrong it might get messed
up as it goes on I've seen two episodes
now but so far all I'm seeing is a good
story wellmade with a character that
happens to be a woman happens to be
Native American and happens to have a
disability
just like Daredevil has a disability
she's using it and making herself
stronger through it it's about fighting
adversity which is a Cornerstone of most
sci-fi most television most
everything
adversity the fact that she's Native
American fine they're using a lot of the
Native American histories and fables Etc
to tell story again I I do wonder how
the Native American people feel about it
that would be interesting to know but
how some white American middle-aged guy
feels about it I don't give a
crap if a Native American comes to me
and says I find it offensive then I
would listen I would be like okay well
why is it offensive that's interesting I
think but
some white privileged [__] is telling
me that this is woke and he's not
watching it and that's thing this [__]
has not watched it and said he won't so
why are you ranting at me about a TV
show you don't even want to
watch if you are going to judge
something watch it first and then judge
it or shut
up if you are not going to give it the
time to at least give it a
chance then don't ever a go about it if
you want to have an opinion on
something you need to make sure you've
actually got an informed opinion
otherwise it isn't an opinion it's just
your emotion you are making an emotional
reaction to something you think you know
about watch the TV show with an open
mind first and then have an informed
opinion otherwise shut
up I have opinions sometimes I'm quite
opinionated I've been told my wife says
particularly but I pride myself on
trying to have opinions that are at
least informed in some way from
knowledge I try to think about what I'm
saying now sometimes as you know if you
watch my lives I say things without
saying without thinking even but I'll
then try to correct myself I'll will
then be open to the conversation open to
the debate and open to change my mind
because changing your mind is important
my wife's dumped a load of clothes on
the floor here I don't know why but
she's while I'm ranting and wanting to
walk around she's put obstacle course
in I don't know why she said that um but
anyway let it go let it
go I personally and this is my opinion
believe that this person that has
messaged me with such vile this morning
is a bigot I don't think that everybody
that shouts woke at things is a biger I
think a lot of people have really
formulated thoughtful opinions based on
the problems they see in an industry
that has had a complicated 10 years with
the MEO movement and everything else an
industry that actually T Fair has been
sexist and racist for pretty much a
century I'm trying to maybe correct it
maybe overcorrected slightly in some
areas and some projects as always a
propaganda or the agenda comes first
so some people that shout woke at things
they shout woke with a thoughtful
opinion based on information and
evidence and they're not
bigoted some people are racist sexist
ignorant
morons and we really need to shout them
out and to really really need to explain
to them why they're wrong and actually
sometimes just point to them and go this
person is a [__] they are basing an
opinion purely on an ignorant bigoted
emotion that they really really need to
stop and
think and
reconsider a very close-minded
opinion watch the show Echo and don't
like it that is absolutely fine
but if you're going to start
shouting things like this you better
have a damn good
reason because just saying you don't
like a show because the star is a
disabled woman Native American really
says more about you than it says about
the
show I am sorry but I had to get that
off my chest if you are new to the
channel not all my videos are like this
so please consider subscribing and
clicking that thumbs up Etc really helps
out the Channel please throw in a
comment cuz I'd love to know what you
guys think about this
and have a nice
[Music]
day